الواقع ربما المر والذي يعمق من هذه
المعاناه حتى فيما يتعلق بالقصف هو انقطاع
الهواتف شبكه الاتصالات وشبكه الانترنت
لليوم الرابع على التوالي وهذه المره
الاولى التي تستمر فيها انقطاع شبكه
الهاتف والشبكه العنكبوتيه لاربعه ايام
متتاليه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب على قطاع غزه
وهذا الامر ربما يفاقم من الواقع الانس
اني حقيقه حتى فيما يتعلق بنداءات
الاستغاثه سواء اسر محاصره او مصابين او
شهداء او حتى عمليات القصف في التي تستهدف
منازل المواطنين تصاب بعرق كبيره جدا جدا
جدا جراء عدم تواصل المواطنين المستهدفين
مع سيارات الاسعاف او مع الدفاع المدني او
حتى مع الصليب الاحمر وبالتالي تصاب هذه
العمليه بنوع كبير من انواع العرقله ويضطر
المسعفون الى الى اللجوء الى وسائل قديمه
مثل سماع الصوت وتحديد اماكن الصوت ومن ثم
التوصل او اذا جاءت سياره مدنيه تحمل بعض
المصابين والشهداء فتدل طواقم الاسعاف على
المنطقه المستهدفه وبالتالي
تتحرك السيارات باتجاه هذا هذا هذه
المنطقه وهذا ينسحب على كل مناحي الحياه
مع الاسف لقد اصبحت المنطقه منطقه خان
يونس لوحدها عباره عن جزر متناثره مناطق
لا تتصل بعضها ببعض وهذا ينسحب على كامل
مناطق قطاع غزه بحيث لم يعد بمقدور اي من
المواطنين التواصل مع بعضهم البعض
للاطمئنان
للتفقيس او المشوره او العون في فاصيبت
الحياه حقيقه بشكل بشلل شبه تام للحياه
وهذا عمق من الواقع الانساني بحيث اصبح كل
اسره كل كل بيت كل مدرسه ايواء كل مستشفى
وكل مركز من مراكز الايواء هو عباره عن
منطقه مستقله
بذاتها متروكه لمصيرها لهذه الدرجه وصلت
الاوضاع هنا في قطاع غزه تحديدا في منطقه
خانيونس مع هذا التصعيد في وتيره القصف
ومع استمرار عمليه انقطاع شبكه الهواتف
وشبكه الاتصالات والانترنت وهو الامر الذي
كما قلنا يفاقم المعاناه الانسانيه ويساهم
الى حد كبير في رفع اعداد الشهداء الذين
هم اصلا يسقطون بالقصف وحتى الجرحى ايضا
يتحولون الى شهداء وبالتالي ترتفع هذه
القائمه تباعا